INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
So now that we know how
to launch EC2 instances,
I think it's time to
actually get in there
and start to do some things.
Probably the most
important skill
within our virtual
machines, and actually
a skill that I've
gotten feedback from,
not only other instructors
but industry members,
people that are looking
to hire students,
the feedback I get from them is
that experience with the Linux
environment and specifically
with a terminal environment
is just one of the
most invaluable skills.
So that's what we're going
to focus on today and maybe
another video or two on this.
But realistically,
everything after this class
or after this
lecture, we're going
to be interacting
with the terminal.
So, I mean, just get familiar
with it, get used to it.
But to kind of highlight
or summarize what it is--
you see it right here behind me.
Here, I'll slide out
of the way again.
The terminal-- right.
The terminal is this
environment, right?
It is this blank
text box that allows
us to go in and submit
commands to the computer,
as we talked about before.
The real strength
of this is that--
OK, well, now I
have this situation,
where I have potentially
any number of computers
that I need to access, virtual
machines that I need to access,
or kind of physical
machines in my office.
If I had to go and
manually plug-in
a monitor, those computers
sit out there with a keyboard,
pull up the user interface,
type the commands
or run, execute the code on it,
or even transfer my code and all
of my resources over
to it, and then run it,
I mean, it would just be such
an expensive, time-consuming
process.
It would require much more
physical space and resources
to do, and it'd just be too
slow to really operate with.
So that's why the
terminal is so powerful.
I mean, again, it's one of those
technologies that has existed as
long as computers have existed.
It's the first way we started to
really interact with, I'll say,
computers that had displays,
because before that, obviously,
we didn't have displays.
And then we were executing
commands more manually on them.
But the second
there was a display,
there was a command prompt or
a terminal to interact with.
So a lot of these
functions and commands
date back to really
early days of computing
and still are widely
used in industry.
So it is a critical
skill in that sense.
And in Cloud computing,
specifically, again,
by its nature, we're saying we
want to interact with or utilize
resources across the internet,
right across vast distances.
And so this is going to
be our portal into that.
So that's what we're
looking at now, right?
This is a terminal.
If you don't see
this yet, to clarify,
make sure you have an
EC2 instance spun up.
So create an EC2 instance.
It's the same way
we've done before.
And then connect to it.
And you should end up at a
screen that looks like this.
If you set up an
Ubuntu environment,
it should say Ubuntu@
some IP address.
So feel free to pause the
video and do that right now,
if you haven't already.
But yeah, we want
to make sure we're
on an EC2 instance with
Ubuntu installed or Ubuntu
as the operating system.
And then that we're
connected to it.
So if you're on a Mac,
go to the terminal
and then do the SSH command.
If you're on Windows,
go to PowerShell,
and then do the SSH
command from there.
But either way, once you're
here, you'll see again.
You'll have the username@
whatever the host is.
And then right
here, actually, this
will specify what the current
working directory is, right?
So we'll come back to
that here in a second.
But this is basically
where we're going
to be interacting with it.
So from a working
directory standpoint,
what we mean by that is
the working directory
is where we're interacting with.
As I said before, this is like
opening up your file explorer
and saying, OK, I want to--
or where am I looking
at these files at?
So if I type pwd that stands
for Print Working Directory
and then I hit Enter, it's going
to return the working directory
where we're sitting at.
So we're sitting in the home
directory in the Ubuntu folder
because that's our user folder.
This is the
equivalent to saying,
I'm on my home directory in
my user folder named Sharad
or whatever my user
folder might be.
The other thing you'll see me
type a million times is ls.
Ls just stands for List.
And actually, you
won't see that.
So let me really quick
remove that file.
You won't see that
file in there.
So yours will just
look like this.
It'll just be blank, and
it'll return nothing.
But what it typically
does is it lists
all the files in a directory.
So, for example,
if you use cd, that
stands for Change
Directory-- and I actually
had to do that before, when we
had to change to the Downloads
folder.
But if I use cd and
then type dot, dot,
that's going to
go up a directory.
So if I do that and then
type pwd, you'll see that,
now, instead of being in
home/ubuntu, I'm just in home.
And for that matter,
it's going to be the--
it'll show that it's in the home
directory right here, in our--
right after the host name.
If I want to get back
to my user directory,
right that home/ubuntu--
well, first, I could do ls.
And I could see that, oh,
well, there exists something
called an Ubuntu folder.
So that is my user directory.
I could change back to
that by typing ubuntu.
Or if we go back for
a second, no matter
where I'm at on my terminal
or what directory I'm in,
I can do cd and then
Shift and type the tilde.
So that's on your top
left of your keyboard,
just below the
Escape key, usually.
And then hit Enter.
And that's always going to
take me to my home directory.
That's why I showed it--
or to my user directory.
So that's kind of the
nickname, in a sense,
for the user directory.
So I'll go back to
the home directory.
And maybe for that matter,
let's go up one more level.
We'll talk about what all
these things mean later on,
but this shows us all the
things that are installed
on this computer right now.
We're at what's typically
called the root directory.
So at the root of the computer.
This is all of the
folders that are
on the computer, all the files.
And it's a lot of things
for all the packages
and libraries installed
in the operating system.
Anything else that's
default on the computer,
it's going to be
somewhere in this folder.
Now, to go take a step
back for a second,
let's talk about these
commands themselves.
So all of our commands,
they consist of, basically,
what the command is.
Then they potentially
have some option.
So in this case, I'm using
dash l as the option.
And then I can also specify
the kind of arguments of this.
So the command in this
case is ls, which is list.
The option is dash l, which
lists more detailed information
about them.
And then the home directory is
an argument to this function.
So if you're familiar
with Python programming,
you'll be familiar with
this idea of an operation
or a function that has arguments
like, what am I trying to do?
Or where am I trying
to apply this?
So if I run this, it's going
to list all of the things
with detailed information
because I did this dash l
in the home directory.
Similarly, I could
have just said--
oh, and actually, what
you're seeing here
as well to this section
here, this funky alphabetic
string here, that
provides information
about the permissions
of this folder.
This tells me something
about who owns the folder
or where it's located.
This tells me the size of it.
So these are all just
more detailed information
that we can get
about, the underlying
or the individual files.
This is the modification date.
So when was the last
time this folder was
modified or anything like that?
And so, again, that
was the command.
This was an option.
And this was the option.
And then this was the argument.
I could have also
just done ls dash l
and not specified
explicitly this argument.
And then it's just
going to assume
I want to do this
operation right here where
I'm at or for this location.
And so now, you can see it
dumped out a lot of information
because it's giving me
a detailed list of all
of the directories.
And directories, again, folders.
Those are synonymous.
So it's giving me a detailed
list of all the directories
in this location right
in my root directory,
with the permissions,
the owners, again,
the size, the last
modified date,
all that sort of information.
So this is, again,
how we're going to be
interacting with the machine.
And if you start to think
about really what a computer is
or how a computer
functions, this actually
covers quite a bit of it, right?
We have files and
folders on there.
I mean, for that matter,
software code is usually
just some sort of file that has
a bunch of files and folders
all smashed together
that do special things.
We're just more used to
having user interfaces that
have a graphical
interaction with it.
But this is just
saying let's strip
that away and just do the
kind of core operations,
in that sense.
So to go back into
it, let's say we
want to go back to
our user directory,
we can just do cd
tilde, or you could--
so you could do that,
or you could do cd.
And we know that home directory
has our user directory.
So that's how we get to there.
And then if we look in here,
well, that's our user directory.
Or for our specific user
Ubuntu, a little cd into there.
And again, just to
clarify, Ubuntu here
is being used as our user name.
So even though it is
the operating system,
it's the default user
name for the primary user
when you create these virtual
machines, these EC2 instances.
So now we have this.
We're in our user
directory, and this
is where typically you're going
to do most of your operations.
We don't often want to
operate at the root directory
because it's like saying, on
my like personal computer,
I don't operate on
the operating system
folders or anything like that.
Typically, I'm using my
Documents, my Downloads folder,
all that stuff, pictures.
So either way, we can create
those folders because right now,
if you do ls, you'll see there's
nothing in this directory.
If I want to create
those folders,
I can do mkdir, which
stands for Make Directory.
And then I can make a folder.
So let's say I want to make
a folder called Documents.
I do mkdir Documents.
And if I do ls,
you can see now, I
have a Documents
folder in there.
I can remove directories.
So I can do rmdir Documents.
And now, if I do ls,
it doesn't exist.
Now, importantly,
though, that only
works if you have
nothing in that folder.
So let's, for a
second, say I do mkdir.
That exists again.
And now, let's say
I want to create
a folder in that directory.
So I'll go cd Documents.
And then from here, if I want to
create a file, all I have to do
or one way I can do this
is to just type touch.
So touch basically
creates a file
or updates the
timestamp of that file.
It's kind of the idea of saying
like, hey, I want to create
a file on my computer.
I'm touching it.
And if it doesn't exist,
that makes it exist.
If it does exist,
then it's going
to just say, hey, somebody
just interacted with that file
recently.
So I'm going to
call it test.txt.
I'm just making a folder or
making a file called test.txt.
So you can see there, now that
shows up in my Documents folder
right when I do ls.
But if I go back one directory
and do rmdir Documents,
notice that it says, fail to
remove directory documents
or directory not empty.
So you can't delete directories
that have information in them.
There is a way to do that
to basically recursively
delete everything in
there, and I'll show you
how to do that eventually.
But it's not something
you want to do every two
seconds because you risk just
deleting a bunch of stuff.
So it's good.
It's important, or
better statement,
it's best practice to
remove irrelevant files.
And then if you get to the
point that you're completely--
if it's a completely
empty directory, then
certainly you can just remove
the directory with that.
Also, I'll say that
I'm not expecting you
to memorize all these commands.
I have a cheat sheet here
that I'm referencing.
I'm going to share this
cheat sheet with you guys
as well, too.
So there's no secret to these.
And by all means,
as well, you'll
find there's a set of commands
that typically you'll use
and you'll memorize yourself.
So not that critical for you
to stress about that right now.
But anyway, touch
creates the file.
Now, as you know, though,
we didn't actually
put anything in that file.
We just said, let's
make it exist.
I mean, if we did ls
dash l in this directory,
you'd see that the size of this
file is zero kilobytes, right?
There's literally no
information in there.
Not a very useful file.
So the question is,
how do we edit a file?
How do we make or add
information to that?
So there are a couple
of ways we can do that.
And basically, all
of them are just
variations of
different text editors.
You can think about it like
opening Microsoft Word.
It's just that it is a
little bit simpler than that.
And that's a strength
as well, too.
That means that it doesn't
take eight years to load,
and it doesn't have all
these crazy features
that you don't need.
It's just to edit text.
So I'll do quite a bit, if
not all, of our programming
in this course in
just this environment.
One text editor that you
can use is called Nano.
So if you just type nano and
then your file name-- if it
doesn't exist, it'll create it.
If it does exist,
you'll just edit it.
Then it pops you into
this new fun window here.
And here I can just say
Sharad is editing this file.
And you'll see
below here, there's
a bunch of things you can do.
There are a bunch of options
that you can interact
with here on these files.
So if I do Command or
Control, depending on --
if you're on Mac, it's
going to be Command.
And if you're on
Windows, I believe
it's going to be Control.
But Control-X-- or
actually no, wrong.
It's Control on both of them.
Control-X and then Y. That was--
and actually, I'll do this again
so you can see here.
So unfortunately, you
can't see my keyboard,
but I'm running this command.
So Control-X. Then I'm
typing Y, because it asks me
yes or no, do I want to save
this file or just x out of it?
And then it's asking me the
file name to write it to,
and then I just hit Enter.
And so that now
has edited my file.
One way I can check that
is to use the cat command.
So cat will just print out all
of the contents of the file.
And so you can see Sharad
is editing this file.
So Nano is one
editor you can use.
vim is another editor.
Again, use whatever you're
most comfortable with.
Looks different,
but functionally
does the same thing,
except with this one.
If you want to edit a
file, you type I first
to put it in insert mode.
You'll see it's now at
the bottom in insert mode.
And then I can go
and make changes.
So I'll go to the end of this.
He did this part using Vim.
And now if I want to
save and exit this file,
I type Escape and
then Shift-Colon.
And you'll see it put a
little colon down here.
And then wq is to save and quit.
Q would just be to quit.
So there are an infinite
number of things
you can do within
Nano, Vim, or whatever
text editor you choose to use.
I'm not by any means picky.
Whatever works best
for you, you use it,
but it's really,
really important
to know how to
edit files on here.
So try Nano, try Vim, Google it.
You'll find infinite, again,
solutions or tips and tricks
on doing that.
Here's two new ones
that I actually
hadn't ever used before,
but found recently.
More prints out the displays,
the contents of the file,
but it does it page by page.
So we only had one page--
or, yeah, one short line
in this file.
But if you had a bunch of pages,
if you did cat in your file,
it would dump out all
of them onto the screen.
And it might overwhelm
your computer
because you have so
much text in there.
More does it page by page.
So it's a good one
to use, and you just
use the Spacebar to kind of
move along through the file.
So a couple different ways to
view the contents of those.
Next, I wanted to show you how
to move and copy files around.
Really simple.
But to show that, let's actually
create another directory here.
So I'm going to
make a directory.
Where are my documents
folder already?
So let's call it, I
don't know, Contracts.
Maybe I have a folder filled
with contracts in them.
Right?
So I have my test.txt file,
and I have my Contracts folder.
Let's say I want
to put my Contracts
folder into my-- or my test
file into my Contracts folder.
Well then I'll use
the mv command.
I'll do test.txt, and
then I'll do Contracts.
And actually, I'll show
you something here.
I can also rename the
file in this point.
So I can do test2,txt.
And now, if I ls, I don't have
any file in my Documents folder.
But if I go to my Contracts,
I have the test2.txt.
So Move is often used
just to rename files, too.
So for example, if I want
to just rename this file,
I can leave it in
the same exact place.
So I'll do test2.txt, and
I'll move it to test3.txt.
So basically, what I'm saying
is move this file from here to--
or from test2.txt in this
directory to test3.txt.
It's the equivalent of
just renaming the file.
Another thing you
can do-- so let's say
I want to move the
test2.txt file back
into my-- or the
test3, I guess, now,
back into my Documents folder.
If I go back into
my Documents folder
with cd dot dot, which, again,
just takes me up a directory,
I can do mv Contracts test3.
And I'm using Tab to
autocomplete that.
So if you ever start to
type something, use Tab.
It'll autocomplete everything.
It's amazing.
So mv Contracts slash
test3.txt and then just dot.
What that says is move
Contracts slash test3.txt,
which is that specific file.
That's a direct path, an
absolute path to that file.
Move that exactly to
right here where I'm at.
So just dot.
It drops it right
here where I'm at.
And now you'll see it's back
here right next to or right back
in my Documents folder.
Copy, similarly, so
we can copy a file.
So let's say I want to copy
it over to the contracts.
I can still use that same
dot syntax, as well, too.
So if we go cd
Contracts, I can do cp.
And now what I'm
going to do is--
again, these are all sorts of
little shortcuts and tricks.
I think this should work.
Dot, dot test3 dot txt dot.
So if we kind of
read what that says,
that says copy from
the directory above.
Remember, dot, dot
takes me up a directory.
So from the directory
above, test3 dot txt.
And then drop it right
here, exactly where I'm at.
And that's what I do with
just the single period.
And I guess I'm
blocking this now.
I hope I wasn't blocking
too many of these.
I realize this in hindsight.
So if you couldn't
see that there,
I was putting an extra
little period after that.
So hit Enter .
Now ls and test3 dot txt
is in my Contracts folder,
and it's also in my
Documents folder.
Finally, as far as
file operations go,
I'm going to remove this file.
So all I have to do
to remove the file is
do rm test3 dot
txt, and hit Enter.
And now it's out of
my Documents folder.
If I go into my
Contracts folder,
though, it should
still be there.
Right?
Because we still have it.
So that is the
high-level description
of how these general
file operations go.
I don't want to get too
much deeper into some
of these other things.
I want to let you practice
with this for a little bit.
And then in the next
video, I'll dive
deeper into some of the more
subtle things or more detailed
things about the terminal.
So play around with this.
You're not going
to break anything.
Again, worst case, you can just
delete everything and start over
again.
But try out some
of these commands,
explore Google, see all the cool
things you can do with this.
I mean, again, now we've been
able to open up a computer
or create a virtual
machine, edit, create files.
And really, that gets
us such a far way
along in the actual Cloud
computing aspect of this, right?
Interacting with a computer
in a Cloud environment.
So we've got a
lot of stuff done.
So either I'll leave it at that.
Next video, we'll step into
some more advanced things
on the terminal.
So thanks.